why are you gay
okay i see what you're doing that's
strike two what is this a baseball game
i don't see any any balls around here
except for ones you know that
now
i'm nervous to ask this but you did say
at the start of the year that you were
considering attempting celibacy is that
something that you have continued with
what time do you finish work
how many times have we worked together
twice no and i haven't seen you in like
five years it's been more it's been less
than five minutes give me this real
quick
just give me a kiss real quick
you're never clean and proper
i'm kidding i'm kid i have a girlfriend
ask the questions okay
it's getting uncomfortable ask the
questions do your job natalie
okay
you have to move out of your chair and
catharine is welcome no no no
no don't do it trust me don't do this
[Music]
oh thank you so just sit here sure i'll
just be here russell look away with my
sexual charisma all right no actually
they it's more like a bikram yoga
really they keep them nice and warm what
does that tell you it tells me you know
what bikram yoga is
do you do bikram yoga i used to have you
ever done it no i've thought about it a
lot though well when i say thought about
it
i'm thinking about you doing it no
it's that's the hot a hot yoga where you
get all sweaty and kind of oh yeah
like that right
that's exactly what they sound like
yeah it was amazing and then we kind of
exchanged numbers and here i was hanging
out with the i didn't meet jim harbaugh
about the first person
yes you're thinking about something yeah
as a matter of fact i was thinking about
something because as you know i've
announced it i find catherine very
attractive then when she said exchanged
numbers i thought things i'd like to
exchange with her
are you still with uh are you still with
john stamos i know you two have been
going out for a long time that
relationship is it falling apart yet
what's going on
why cody
[Applause]
[Applause]
i usually enjoy sitting next to the
guest because why won't you sit next to
me it's rude
it's not rude i requested it i called my
agent i want to
sit next to you
good to see you cause you're on
paternity leave last night
i love it
i lived in europe for a while that's how
we came that is how you yeah that's how
we talk about videos
i don't have
when i was younger i would have probably
been found ideas like a pickup artistry
attractive yeah but when you get a
little more sophisticated you realize
that there is no way of tricking anybody
into doing things that they don't want
to do that can be anything but negative
for both parties involved so what is
your secret uh my secret is that i know
that within you there is a limitless
divine beauty and within me as well and
if i connect with that
then we'll be okay and you as well
thank you chris for god
he's good for everybody everybody's
going to myself ready
hi secretariat
[Music]
i think he's very excited to see you
i've never seen you hey how are you i'm
good
how you doing warm you up hey
all right so we never know exactly what
our next guest is going to do when he
kind of roars through our studio yes you
know bobby lee from mad tv harold and
kumar go to white castle and this
weekend he'll be in the chicago area at
the improv to make audiences laugh it is
a friend of the show
he can never quite get on this couch
gracefully do you um
uh i was gonna you've thrown me but i i
love that you you're throwing me if
you're ever so confused fifi box pop
yourself down on my knee and see if we
can't get you pregnant
excellent and my mum's not watching this
morning so that's a good thing too why
is your mum not watching what's she
going on oh no she's busy she's way with
a friend at the moment bring her in
i'll take the liars i have a zit right
here too you're the one who knows i hate
those
[Laughter]
i'm not even japanese i shouldn't say
that joke
guys well here's the deal right i have a
cat
i know
okay
well i'm not surprised that's what i'm
saying what are you trying to say i'm
saying when i look at you i think
yeah
well in so many words yeah
i like an suv right to keep your cat
steam i put my cat in when we go to the
vet
you go to the vet a lot
is your [ __ ] sick all the time
well i'm asking about
[Applause]
forget it okay forget your cat don't
forget your cat
no you must what's wrong is your cat
she's fine oh okay good good
i was worried you i thought you'd left
her in the suv no that's bad you must
have never i'm trying to defend my non
you know priusey car that i own
but i've scratched the rocket out of it
so
wait a minute
before before you bleep it man
look at her
just give her what she wants you have it
you have a bag down there yeah i'm
look in our bag sorry pete or lara's
legs yes sexist
sam i hope you're watching this it's not
me you want to worry about it's pete
at the back
russell russell like you're from
another dimension yeah england i brought
you some tanning i like that
that's racist
[Laughter]
anyway it's instant
is this a product placement
by lara bingle hey what's your name
well i just got married so i'm i'm doing
the research
are you rebranding it yeah eventually
[Applause]
well someone's enjoying it
[Applause]
this is what it is about sports is that
in everything else uh
it's subjective you know what i mean
they could say that you're the greatest
uh uh woman alive the most beautiful and
you are beautiful
well thank you
if you took my pulse right now you'd
have to subtract five
other people could say oh she's not
beautiful what are you talking about
sure you know right so it's all it's all
just opinion with everything i see it's
not subjective but sports
yes you have a number it's a winner and
a loser yes
very straightforward it's like math it's
math you have a number people can't
argue you have a number
[Music]
[Music]
talk to donuts when you eat them i like
my donuts so fat their holes are closed
does that make me creepy i don't know
you know for years i couldn't work and
then this year something magical
happened and what was that i don't know
i just have this confidence
and i have this um i just i want to go
for it you know what i mean
and um just
it never works
she doesn't like ethnics
that is not true
i'm wide i have jaundice
can you say those kind of jokes here
huh i know it's television
you are the only person ever in the in
my career here to get that close to my
face he's the only person get that
closer
no so does that mean it doesn't matter
then yes
yes it's not working out though
it doesn't feel like it is no yeah your
energy is like it's a little too strong
i have a relationship and how's yours
going really good really yeah how long
have you been together four years and
it's strong it's really strong yeah and
she's way better than you
i'm kidding i'm very nice to meet you
and may i compliment you on your amazing
shoes thank you
that's really something you got going on
there i noticed a shoe from time to time
you do well you know it depends but yeah
look at that yeah i can see it but leave
it there i can see it better
that's that's an amazing shoe is that
the the roman sandal they're calling
that this is sort of dominatrix yeah oh
i knew i'd seen it somewhere
we managed to get tickets uh for the
super bowl fun and when i say we i mean
my husband
yeah but you you know look at the way
you've dropped the jets you could drop
that guy any day
[Music]
absolutely stop dancing
don't face the change no
changes
yeah i imagine you'd probably ski in a
kind of tight little outfit
well
like like this i just go like this you
wear that skateboard
in my mind you do for sure
where are you headed off to for your
dinner break
my stupid friend
a stupid friend
disappeared
so i don't know do you know a place
called borgia or something like that
a seafood restaurant here you want me to
walk you there is it close yeah
yeah that'd be great all right
we'll figure it out we'll sign off here
we'll figure it out i may have it i may
have a different date with norman who
were these then were there i don't know
but i they're fancy though i like them i
feel like they should stay on
oh yeah i like that you know
you know what i mean
until i get home
stay on this show stay on the show yeah
yeah absolutely what were you thinking
oh come on come on get your mind out of
the gutter i believe that uh male
heterosexuals are more attracted to
slightly larger uh females
okay yeah
you got any cookies back there yeah
you want some tea
it's true though i have to tell you that
every time i eat myself up a little bit
your husband my husband frisky yeah
that's right he gets a little hands-on
right i love it's great you see what
happens is i think dress designers are
like no you've got to be thin so that
the clothes look like that but you see
men who are not involved in dress design
they're not caring about the clothes
staying
on exactly like maybe it's you know and
if it's too uncomfortable take it off
yeah
that's fine but the shoes stay on is
that isn't that very good yeah
that's very good come on